okay here I go again
putting in my two cents
everyone has two cents to put in and
everyone's philosophy quite often is
kind of designed to help you get through
Life as We Know It
but I was talking about alligator hide
and you have to be tough like that and
resilience
to be able to ward off negativity I mean
people have said to me words don't mean
anything unless they're true that's not
true words hurt
words are the same as a thorn on a rose
they look nice but boy some of them can
really hurt
did anyone ever
study an alligator
crocodile
and wonder how they survived
so many hundreds of millions of years
thick skin
almost impervious
shape that is an element that I think is
so necessary
in this day and age
to be successful challenge all right
that's a given you have to have some of
that ambition yeah you got to have a
hell of a lot of that
and this fear of failure
good help into that certainly
inspires one to get out of bed in the
morning but the most important thing is
the alligator hide you have to be able
to take criticism
I believe that some of the most talented
people in the world fail because they
can't take the criticism they're too
sensitive
they're artistic part of them
just can't withstand the withering
intellectual verbal bullets that rip
them to shreds in other words criticism
believe me I was told
a thousand times
well not a thousand but a few hundred
you're not cut out for this
you slur you're this relax
uh we can't
fit you into any kind of category you
should really quit seriously but you
know what you should work behind the
scenes
and when well yeah thank you for that
but everything you're saying is bouncing
off
it's like bulletproof and that's what
I'm trying to pass on to individuals
that you have to be able to be like a
solid tree
we all share
certain traits
for example I don't like to argue I
don't like stress
I don't like conflict but sometimes you
have to face
the conflict and the stress and the
source of that
and get it out of the way don't keep it
inside
somehow
you have to purge yourself of this thing
that's eating you alive there's
different ways of doing it getting into
someone's grill or
you start to use your head
and work your way around the problem
without offending anyone but you're
getting your point across but sometimes
you just have to
offend someone who's offending you
that's fair
and it takes courage
actually it takes courage to do a lot of
things
it takes a lot of guts
to stay in school it's courage it takes
courage to get up every morning in
bravery and pushing yourself when you
don't want to to go to work just to
apply food for yourself and your family
it takes courage to stick your head
above the crowd and voice your own
opinion even though it's not a popular
one
but it's one that you feel is so deep in
your soul that
you have to get it out
you can't go through life
living on lies quite often you just have
to stand up
and grab Life by the throat and not let
go until you succeed courage
you all have it
it's just pushing the red button
keep punching am I going to be
caught in this time warp called the past
because quite often let's face it your
problems are from the past if you didn't
get the attention you wanted in the
first five years being nurtured you're
gonna have a problem for the rest of
your life with Mercury and feeling
secure for example I feel that nurturing
and compassion and love and protection
at a very early age meaning when your
infant is more of a priority than food
and when you don't get that when you're
young
you crave it your whole life and quite
often it's also an incentive
to do something with your life
to fill it up with some sense of
accomplishment or it's a release for
anger whatever it is quite often I have
found that the most damaged people have
been the most productive I know it's a
horrible thing to say but
people that are missing chunks in their
heart
gaps in their soul because they weren't
given the love and attention
when they're very young that can't be
compensated for those are holes those
doors are shut so it's up to you to lay
the groundwork
for your future to not do what other
people did to you
so it's juggling juggling juggling
juggling juggling so here's to you all
keeping all these objects in the air
and knowing that
it's never perfect
life is one big juggling act it's like
how do you keep all these objects going
around and then when you drop a few you
got to pick it up again but it's
juggling
you juggle happiness
with grief that's a rough one because
grief never goes away it sort of Rises
into the clouds you might say it's sort
of seems as though it's diminishing and
it does until something brings it back
in there and is the cycle that's why
quite often
I find therapists
for certain individuals
a fruitless exercise because quite often
these problems can't be extracted bad
memories can't be pulled out and
diminished they're there
you just have to balance it
I've come across some of the most
miserable people that have everything
except what is truly important and that
is
peace of mind
and going forward
without
fear
fearlessness
it's not easy sometimes you have to lie
to yourself oh I'm not afraid you're
terrified
but sometimes lying is good
if that helps get you up those first
three steps into the Ring of Life to
face the indestructible opponent so be
it lie to yourself
sometimes lying gets the ball going
[Music]